[Music]
on today's show we talk about hard
conversations we talked to a woman whose
husband made their baby the beneficiary
in the life insurance policy we talked
to a man who's dating a woman whose
parents are way too involved we talked
to a woman who cheated on her husband
and she wants to know how to tell her
stay tuned
[Music]
ratatt what's up this is jon with the dr
john delony show how we doing hope
you're doing well on this show we talk
about relationships and mental health
and friends and family
and man
james you got a look on your face did i
screw up no we were just discussing the
uh significance of the rattata tap yeah
dude it's old school
i just gotta stop there there's a band
called ratatat really
do they just play songs for
mice i don't know ratata are they
like a metal band
i think they're like a german um
guitar drum kind of duo thing i forget
they're good though i like the white
stripes called rattat
i kind of support the name of that band
i like it i like it but hey if you want
to be on this show not one of james
german metal band shows
did you have it'd be so great if you had
a tournament middle band show like a
whole life nobody knew about um give us
a shout johndaloni.com
ask
ask johndeloney.comaskorg go to 1-844
call don't go to call 1-844-693-3291
i would love to have you on the show and
we are close to the holidays
december this show comes out late
december right
yeah so either you've already done all
of your shopping
or you're going to be staring at your
kids on christmas eve and be like santa
hosed us
santa did not show up
which is a great if you wonder if you're
on the fence about whether you should
tell your kids about santa this may be
the year just because uh you didn't go
shopping but speaking of that i
often not often i always tell people
don't
lie to your kids don't lie to your kids
don't lie to your kids don't lie to your
kids and the most common question i get
when i say don't lie to your kids is
what about santa claus
so tomorrow uh kelly let me know we have
a call coming in tomorrow and there's a
split family over this issue and we're
gonna dig into it so make sure you
circle back to the show um when the next
one that releases but we'll be talking
about it
but we are in the holiday season hey
kelly have you done all your shopping
not yet but i've started yeah
and you bought a house congratulations
thank you yes we did we uh closed last
week and we move in next week the
success of this show launched pushed you
over the edge right yeah you were
middling along doing that other show and
then this one came along and blam right
it just sent us into a completely new
financial bracket that's incorrect
man as most podcasts do as most podcasts
do
oh man so good let's just stop right
there let's go to liz in charlotte north
carolina what's up liz how are we
hey dr gone i'm blessed to be stressed
how are you you're blessed to be
stressed
that is
maybe one of the worst best rhymes of
ever ever you should be a rapper
so what's up
so
my husband
of three and a half years wait wait time
out time out time out i just got that
i'm blessed to be stressed
that means you have like a job and
you're
you've got kids and stuff so things are
go okay i got it
i'm blessed to be stressed i like it do
you have that on a pillow somewhere in
your house
so i have it on my computer printed off
of a label maker of course you do this
one of the teachers i had in high school
had it on her computer and it's just
been something that always
resonated with me so i i love it i think
you should get it tattooed on your wrist
i think that's where the cool kids get
tattoos these days all right so now
we're back so what's up your husband and
you and then what
okay so my husband of three and a half
years brought to my attention uh
recently that i am not the beneficiary
on his life insurance policy what i
don't think that he's going to die
tomorrow um he might if he doesn't if
you don't
put you as a bit of who did he please
please god tell me he put like an old
girlfriend please please please please
why um our two and a half our
two-year-old daughter
is the soul um
on the policy
why
i don't know that's one of the reasons
why i'm calling i guess to
try and
figure out and have a discussion with
him
so when he told you this what did you
say
um i kind of thought he was joking
and then he went on to be like oh you
know i'm putting it and if anything
happens to me it'll go on an escrow
account she won't be able to touch it
till she's 18. and then it kind of just
got my brain
circling and thinking like
again no i don't think you're gonna die
tomorrow but
but hey we have a house he might
right so i mean yeah two big red flags
for me
can i tell you the biggest red flag is
not the one you think
the biggest red flag is you have been
together three and a half years how long
did you date before that
so
about two and a half okay i've known him
for about 12. six years you all have
been lovers 12 years so
he tells you this something in you
didn't immediately start
causing a ruckus
why did you stay quiet when he said that
that that is the worst possible
financial decision he could make unless
he doesn't trust you he's planning on
leaving you and doesn't want to have to
deal with a lawyer later
um
giving
he's going to leave his life insurance
money for 18 years if he dies tomorrow
and then you just gotta raise this kid
with no money like what that makes no
sense but
before that why didn't you say anything
i think that's kind of just been the
whole
uh summary of our relationship again i
kind of thought he was joking
he had mentioned before we got married
his brother his stingy brother was going
to be in charge
and then we got married and had a child
but this is not our only child um i have
a daughter from a previous relationship
that he adopted
after we got married okay he was eight
and a half
does he not want that kid to have
the money
i think it's the first part of your
sentence he doesn't want that case
but he adopted that kid so that ship
sailed
i know
there's other issues i'm telling you
yeah
i
for sure
uh there's other issues
hey i don't i don't mean to be
ah man
no please be because we've seen a
marriage counselor your marriage is in
big big trouble that's what i'll tell
you
big trouble
100 agree with you okay
big trouble and
he's either having conversations about
you and his situation
with other people and that's where he
got this advice
he is
creating hell in his home by adopting
another child
marrying somebody who had another kid
but trying to
cut that kid out of his life
and which is just gonna
wreak havoc on your family
um on your biological kid on this
adopted kid on your marriage every i
mean what a mess
and then that
there's a hard thing to have a
conversation about and this doesn't even
sound like a hard conversation to me but
there being a hard conversation
um
you can't have it
what's at the root of this thing
uh
we've
i guess everything in our in our life
and our relationship has been
a hundred miles per hour since we began
our relationship he was in one before
for about seven years i was previously
married
and have we haven't slowed down pumped
the brakes the entire time how'd y'all
get together
so we met in college
uh
about 12 years ago 11 and a half 12
years ago
he was in a previous relationship i was
in a relationship i ended up getting
married
ended up having a child ended up
getting separated uh due to infidelity
and divorce
on your part on your portion
yes and so when
my husband and i
um
we kind of rekindled through social
media
um lived in the same town basically
growing up um and then we
i was an adult then but i was always
taught that
like
with divorce my parents have been
married for about 35 years now but
if it's not broke you don't you fix it
you don't throw it away but after three
different times of infidelity from my
first
husband i just couldn't deal with it
anymore um and so we got divorced and
again i rekindled with my
now husband is he cheating now
my husband yeah
i really hope not
you know the answer to that question
it's a yes or no
no no okay um
here's here's the deal so to answer your
original question yes
the only
thing that makes any rational sense
whatsoever
is that you are the sole beneficiary
and then your
two kids or the
your mutual beneficiaries and if you
have a life insurance policy which you
should
even if it's a small one he he should be
your sole beneficiary
and there shouldn't be any discussion
about taking care of these children
and i think
my wife and i set up a trust so it goes
into the trust so if we buy things
whatever it all goes into there and it
gets distributed a certain amount but
um
even the folks that we have that if my
wife and i were to die our kids would go
to a couple
they have full access to that money and
here's why i wouldn't have picked them
if i didn't trust them
to take my children and a lot of people
will put more emphasis on who's what's
the deal with the money than they do
with who gets their children
but i trust him and so they may need to
build another house they may need to
move they need to get another car they
need to do whatever
and i trust him now i'm going to have
money for my kids college and all that
but
um i
yeah this signal's a mess this signals
somebody who's either about to get out
of a relationship
this signals somebody who doesn't like
the current relationship that they're in
is trying to pick and choose parts of it
but it's a bigger signal that you all
are not on the same page
and you got to get on the same page you
said y'all been running and gunning and
running and running and running for
seven years
y'all just gonna run off the edge of a
cliff if you're not careful
how do you get that back how do you stop
and just say whoa whoa whoa let's we
need to talk
uh we've seen a marriage coach for a
little over almost a year now uh
in a year you'll have not received any
coaching on how to get on on skills on
how to
stop in the middle of a hard
conversation and be vulnerable with one
another
that means your marriage therapist is
terrible
if y'all been seeing them for a year and
you don't have any tools or the courage
or the strength or any of the insights
into
having a hard conversation terrible
do you think
no it is
again i thought he was joking it's
but then i'm you know rethinking it over
and over again and i'm like well if
something does happen to him it's like
i'm gonna have to move not only am i
going to be grieving my
dead husband but i'm going to have to
move
our two children because i would have we
would have to sell the home if i'm not
on this policy and i did bring it back
up to him
and he was like
you know well there's ways to get around
her being the only person on there no no
yeah there's one
you write it down
oh my gosh yeah so
you'll need to have this conversation
asap and i
if you need to go back and see a
marriage coach there's something you're
here
are you safe are you an abusive
relationship
um
mentally more than physic definitely not
physically but mentally he's
definitely said some things that
[Music]
have
shot daggers to the heart and he doesn't
understand the
he thinks that it's all okay that he can
just apologize and
it'd be fine the next day but then these
things keep being brought back up and
give me an example of
one um
i didn't marry you because i loved you
um i married you so that we could adopt
child's name
and i didn't hear this until the
adoption was final in
july of 2018 and i didn't hear this
until our
about a year ago
so does your house he was the one who
brought up the
divorce
i've never brought that up until about
the 10th time when i was like you know
what i can't
take this
like how many times are you going to say
it before it actually becomes real it
mean that he wants to get a divorce
correct yeah
that
going back to the very first thing
without knowing that his actions tell me
that he's got a foot out of this deal
that just doesn't make any sense
at all
at all
and by the way you want to ruin your
child's life give all of your money to
one sibling and not the other
killer great idea
unbelievable yeah so
y'all
this is a lot liz and so here's what
i'ma tell you
um
i'm just gonna rattle off three things
off top of my head okay
have you seen somebody on your own
yes
how's that going
um it was our same
counselor
and it was
due to
he kind of gave me an ultimatum if i
didn't see somebody
by myself by that date
are you are you
are you stable are you okay
am i okay uh-huh
like what why would he give you that
ultimatum
because he's um not a nice person
why do you think so little of yourself
liz
who told you this is what your life was
worth
he did
now before him somebody told you before
him
probably my ex who cheated on me
multiple times okay
i want you to go see a different
somebody
somebody who's gonna pour into you and
walk alongside you
not just doing stuff as you kind of work
not as kind of as you work towards
healing
you got two little ones that are
watching everything
and you look at yourself in the mirror a
few times every day
and you're just simply worth more than
this
i see it every listener on this call is
gonna hear it
anybody watching this is gonna see it
and you don't see it
and you're worth more than this
and so the first thing i want you to go
work on your healing you got to go talk
to somebody and say i need to heal and
i've been
emotionally beat up by a couple of men
and i deserve more than this and i don't
even know where to start
the second thing is
is you need to
write this stuff down for you get out of
your head and get on a piece of paper
these things that make you feel not safe
and if my husband's got secret money
accounts if he is giving
life insurance money to our baby and not
to me um there are some major trust
issues i wouldn't feel safe in that
situation and i know i know i know
there's other stuff going on here
there's the things he says to you like i
don't even love you i don't even know
how we're married except for this kid
what whatever it happens to be i want
you to write this stuff down and third
you got to have a hard conversation
not in the fight but don't set it up
that way but you got to go somewhere and
be on top of it
and be direct and say
your comment about or your decision to
put all the money in in the hands of an
18 month old or a two-year-old
um
broke me it's about enough
and you tell me you didn't get married
because he loved me you tell me you're
to divorce me divorce me divorce me to
voice me yet
you're willing to leave me destitute if
you pass away leave me and our other
child destitute or all three of us until
you got to see all that stuff out loud
then you'll have to decide if this
marriage is worth going forward or not
because right now it's not
now it's a mess
and i want you all to stay married but
you're going to have to
lean into this
and i want you to walk with a
professional because something tells me
you're not telling me the full story and
something tells me that you're really
struggling right now okay
we're with you liz
go see somebody make that call today
this is the morning so you got all day
to make that call and not the one you've
been seeing make a new call today be
right back on the dr john de luna show
hey good folks and friends and listeners
to the dr john dolone show
the world is bonkers right we all know
this and one of the most common
questions i get is how do i find a
counselor in the chaos i've reached out
and there's a six month waiting list or
i can't afford it or they only take
insurance or i can't get off work and
time to go see somebody it's way across
town what do i do because i want help
with my anxiety my depression my
relationships are hanging on by a thread
i want to be a better mom i gotta
process this trauma that happened to me
when i was a kid
where do i find a counselor
so i partnered with better help because
betterhelp is customized online therapy
that offers video phone even live chat
sessions so you don't even have to look
at your therapist when you're talking to
them if you don't want to i've taken
away all your excuses and it's more
affordable than in-person therapy and
these are real licensed therapists if
you reach out to them you will be
talking to somebody within 48 hours dr
john dolone show listeners get 10 off
their first month at betterhelp.com
please reach out if you need help that's
betterhelp.com
all right we are back man that one's
still stuck
that one's still uh
stuck in my soul a little bit
oh man all right let's go to michael in
shreveport what's up michael
hey dr john how are you i'm all right
man what's going on
so um i have a question so
how do i um bring out more confidence
and comfort from my girlfriend's parents
who seem to be a little overprotective
and a bit controlling
like is there something i can do or is
it just going to take time um
i want to go just a little bit into my
situation i don't want to take up too
much time explaining everything but both
of us are 21 years old
we've been together for
about six months very strong
relationship she's a phenomenal person
all around
and the parents are a little involved in
a relationship um you know what's that
mean every time we it's something i'm
sorry what's that what does that mean
that they're they're
kind of involved
so she tells her anything
she
tells them everything we do everything
we talk about um
sometimes when we go out to say dinner
or something they'll come along um
they're phenomenal people very
respectful
respectable very hard working loving but
sometimes they get a little you know
restrictive on the time we spend um
outside of say school we spend a lot of
time
on campus and all
um
is there just something i can do to gain
a relationship with her parents without
ruining the family dynamics like how can
i get more trust out of them to where
they'll allow her to spend more time
with me
oh man um it's a great question dude
there's a lot going on here
um
they sound
pretty amassed for having a 21 year old
right i agree um
now it's not weird that they go out to
dinner with you and all that kind of
stuff but it's weird that they're
i don't know my parents didn't have that
level of of
control over my time when i was 21 or 20
or 19.
yeah
and it turns out it's not just me
um there are times when she'll tell me
you know
uh they won't even let her spend time
with her best friend um and they she
even does she live at home
uh yes she does um okay so here's the
thing you are you're dating a child
okay and i want you to think of it that
way
she has been alive 21 years old i mean
21 years but she's a child
and she's
acting like one and she's being treated
like one
and so
you feel like this is a grown-up
relationship because of your age and
it's not and so if you're okay dating a
high school kid
and then you're gonna live by those
rules and so be it
um
she's gonna have to decide this has
nothing to do with her parents that's
just the dynamic they've set up she's
gonna have to decide i'm a grown up and
i wanna spend time with who i to spend
time with and i'm going to begin to
develop boundaries between me and my
parents
and that might mean i got to get my own
place and pay my own rent that might
mean i got to get my own place pay my
own rent and then i'm going to have to
pay tuition because my parents are
immature and they're going to cut me off
or they may have been trying to kick her
out for years and she's whatever you
know you know what i mean so this issue
is less with their parents and more with
her
what is it about her
that is
worth
having a high school dating relationship
again
it's
we've just been uh knowing each other
for a long time and um
i've just been praying
like for years for um somebody to enter
my life and i feel you know a great
connection with her we get along
extremely well
um
we talk every day you know it's just
overall a great relationship with a
great person and she's just so worth
keeping and fighting for in my mind
okay
um
i'm going to strongly recommend you
don't go to war with her parents you'll
lose
oh
everybody
i do not want to ruin the family
dynamics and that's why i'm you know
well you don't you don't have that power
quite honestly right
you're not strong enough to ruin this
family dynamic i can see you all getting
married and then in five years
when she her mom is still in the middle
of y'all's life and you have one kid
another one on the way that you snap
and say this is our house not their
house this is our marriage our sexuality
our parenting our life not theirs
and that's what you're going to be
dealing with in two years and five years
and 10 years and 20 years if y'all don't
have boundary discussions now
right
and i'll tell you this man i got a lot
of a lot a lot of great great great
friends great friends men and women
i couldn't marry them
you know what i mean and they bring a
lot of really wonderful things to my
life but we're not married
and what i'm telling you is you're in
for a long haul with this relationship
oh that i i kind of went in knowing that
okay but um you know i i just
you know in my mind it's just worth it
for her
because here's what they're doing just
so
they are not
they are still parenting her as though
she's a child
yes
and so they have autonomy over her time
in her space and her physical presence
probably what she says
um
inviting themselves to think do they pay
for a lot of stuff
um
you talking about her parents right
uh-huh
um
i'm not are you talking about like our
her life or uh when we go out and do
something both both
to be honest she does pay her own bills
like under her house she does pay you
know her insurance and she has a
loan for uh college and all she pays for
herself in fact she has a job and she
runs her own business out of her house
um and when
we go out and do stuff you know i always
take care of myself and her okay so when
you have you asked her about her
enmeshment have you said hey
it seems weird that you're 21 and your
parents are still restricting your time
like this
um i haven't brought that up but she has
said um you know
every now and then when we talk she has
that you know
this has been in the back of my mind i
kind of want to find a higher paying job
and move out
um
but at the same time you know she's
almost done with college and she's about
to go to culinary school and she plans
on staying at home for culinary school
okay so here's a an important part of of
relationships anyone like this that you
see any kind of future with
is no secrets
tell the truth
the good stuff and the tough stuff
now you can weaponize this you can
weaponize truth
and what i mean by that is instead of
saying
um when somebody asks you hey do i look
good in this be like
that's not my favorite shirt
or you wore something last week that was
great that's different than oh my gosh
you look like a beach toy i mean you can
say you can be abusive with truth right
right um
but you can also be honest
this is a moment for your young
relationship
to young people in a young relationship
where you can be honest
right
so i mean your parents are around a lot
i would love to see us move into a
situation where
they have less control over
us over me over you
um what would it look like for you to
get your own place when you're in
culinary school
and
what would that look like for us to not
bring them on dates with us anymore
whatever that looks like you know what i
mean it can be any number of things but
you need to have that conversation
because it's weighing on you
and i tell you to have this conversation
if about any number of other things the
other six months in and if this one
conversation here is really important
okay so hear me closer michael
if you are nervous to have this one
conversation
because you're afraid it might hurt the
relationship it might end the
relationship
i'm gonna tell you this relationship
ends at some point
it ends
more catastrophically than it would now
if you already aren't having hard
conversations or telling the truth or
holding a little bit of secrets here and
a little bit of secret zero or you're
frustrated and you clinch your fist and
you're not seeing it six months in
that does not bode well for the future
of this thing
and she may be
giving you little
hints of hey man this is really hard for
me and she wants you to bring it up but
she doesn't know be honest be honest
and what i'll tell you is it's worth you
being honest
not having secrets telling her how you
really feel
in a respectable dignified way
and seeing if the relationship is strong
enough to hold those that truth
then finding it out ten years down the
road that it's not or seven years down
the road or three years or whatever it
is so yes i think you should have sit
down have that conversation there's not
a lot you can do with her parents other
than to keep showing up and treating
their daughter with dignity and respect
be a person of integrity work really
hard
but man there's nothing worse than some
guy that's trying to all butt kisses
his girlfriend's parent it's just gross
just be be you man be totally 100 you
be a person of character work really
hard give them the impression that
you're somebody worth spending time with
their daughter the conversations between
her daughter
and her parents your girlfriend and her
parents because she's got to grow up
we'll be right back on the dr john de
luna show
y'all know there are lots of things that
make me nuts but one thing makes me more
nuts than anything else
buying a home and my friends who
refinance their homes they tell me it
makes them nuts too
i love living in a new home but i gotta
be honest
i'm no good at buying one and that's why
i'm so thankful for people like my
friends at churchill mortgage churchill
is a ramsey trusted provider who we've
been sending people to for over 20 years
to help with home mortgages why
because they're committed to doing
what's right for you and that means
walking you through paperwork that's way
over your head that means making sure
you get the right mortgage that you can
pay off as soon as possible and they'll
try to upsell you a bunch of nonsense
that's going to hurt you down the road
and most importantly when you're making
this big life change you can actually
breathe because you got an expert and a
team who have your back listen if you're
about to buy a home and make a big
change
save yourself the headache and call
churchill mortgage today at triple eight
loan 200. trust me that's triple eight
loan 200.
this is a paid advertisement in mls id
1591 in the mls consumer access dot org
equal housing lender 1749 mallory lane
suite 100 brentwood tennessee 37027
programs are for select loan types only
and are not available in all states or
locations
all right let's take unimas let's go to
natalie in atlanta georgia what's up
natalie how are you doing
hi i'm pretty good how are you good i
love uh
pretty good what's the
what's the uh what's the not pretty part
i can't wait um
well it's unfortunate actually so
i'm a little nervous just because i
haven't told anyone and it's like now i
tell the world so this is just great but
okay before before you say this why did
you pick this this forum to do this
um because i need advice from a
trustworthy source other than google and
i listen to your show and um google is
not a good place i've found it's a dark
sad place
yeah a lot of strange information but
it's this show has been helpful to me
and it's a trustworthy source so i came
here um to get some advice i appreciate
that i'll do the best i can you'll get
what you pay for how about that
okay great
um so i have made a horrible mistake and
about two months ago
i
found myself in an unhealthy
relationship
at the gym
um i
wait back out are you married are you
married yes i am married that's the key
how long that's the key problem um we
have been married we're about five years
any kids five years
two children two and four okay
um so i
wanted to do a fitness competition and i
found myself at the gym a lot and there
was a guy there trainer and
basically started
you know helping me out with some
workouts we started talking
and it went too far um
um well
he started talking to me we met for
coffee
and then the part did you sleep with him
we actually ended up sleeping together
yes which is the part that my husband
doesn't know he knows everything
except for that because immediately i
just feared risking
like i was scared of losing everyone and
i was so stupid and i was like just
scared so i immediately lied
and
blocked him from everything i have not
communicated with him since then
and over two months but now i'm like
well great when it was all horrible
i lied and now i don't know if i should
rehash this because things have been
going really well and like we've
really surrounded ourselves with a great
community and church family and
counseling and i have lied so hard about
this one thing yeah among every single
person because in my head i was like
i'll just never ever bring this up
and now i'm like
do to move forward i need to know
whether or not i should tell
the fact that you're calling tells me
that you know the answer to this
well
google said the other way i was like
well maybe i could get out of this
maybe that's not a good idea um
so you
number one
bravery
bravery thank you for saying this out
loud
go back in when you when you listen to
this call your voice changes after you
say it out loud
okay
take a big deep breath and then drop
your shoulders all the way down
so in your gut what do you think you
should do
um i probably need to tell them
no probably like what what do you need
to do
i feel like i need to tell him because
i feel like if i don't it's just going
to be
preventing us i guess from
truly living honestly
yeah
will this end everything
i
i don't know if it will i don't think it
will i just think it's
going to make it harder
i don't know what it'll do i mean he is
definitely forgiving and
really understanding but i mean you all
have been in counseling and you've
talked about this
and we've talked about everything and
i've just totally denied
doing anything more than just
communication meeting and all that okay
so
i am just i'm like oh my goodness and
y'all just hooked up one time
yes
it was the hook up and then done
and everything kind of hit the fan
like as in he found out about us
communicating and
and it was like almost like a rescue for
me because it was just not going to go
well from there yeah
that's right
but when everything's starting to look
better i just hate having to rehash all
this
yeah
that's why i've
tried to find a way out i guess what
does your counselor tell you
um well i've actually we have never met
one-on-one so we're doing it through our
church and it's the couple's counseling
okay and so i still haven't even been
honest with the counselor because i
would have to say it in front of both of
them and i'm like
i don't know if he low-key knows or
something but
because i don't know but
he hasn't really told me anything he
about it because no one knows
so here's what i'll tell you
your husband knows
okay and he doesn't
he might not know that y'all slept
together
he might not know that y'all did
anything above what you told him
but he knows there's a gap between the
two of you
yes
and he's going to counseling he's doing
what he
thinks he's supposed to be doing
and that gap is getting wider
because as he leans in there's a part of
you that leans out because you know
is that right yep that would be
accurate and so what i'll tell you is
beyond the right thing in the integrity
thing and all that stuff
you're torturing a man that you love
and he doesn't even know it
no i sound like i'm talking on both
sides of my mouth i said he knows but
then he doesn't even know it
he knows there's a gap there and he
doesn't know what it is
right
right
i see that
and in some ways it feels better because
he's trying to do everything he can to
jump over that thing and you are too
there's a part of you that's trying to
and there's part of you that's anchored
to still chained to another thing
right
right
so here's what i'll tell you
i'll tell you you screwed up and you
know that
the season of life y'all are in with a
two-year-old and a four-year-old
um
is hard and you're not the only one
that's ever done that okay
i'm not trying to make it right i'm
trying to say you're not alone
right
and you screwed up
and the measure now is
what's next that's what you can control
yeah
okay so you called me knowing what i'm
gonna say anyway right
yeah i kind of yeah i did
um and if you need me to be the person
in your life that tells you that i think
i think your
husband's worth being honest too
i think you're being you're worth not
walking around your life um
dragging
a
load of bricks around with you
okay
and i think you need to be very aware
this may end everything
yeah he may say i'm out
right because you did this and because i
can't trust you and be fill in the blame
or he may need some space and some time
and all those things
um okay
it'll be hard
but what i know is that relationships
can't survive big secrets
okay and i know there's all stories on
the internets and all that kind of stuff
um yeah that talk about i didn't say
anything for 90 years it was the best
decision ever made are great cool yeah
you found those right
yeah hoping they would be the right
immediately and i was like oh thank
goodness i'd never have to bring this up
and then it just ate me bite at me about
what we really need to do yeah
so so uh role play this with me real
quick how does it work
that's my next question like i
i don't know because there's never a
good time like the kids are sick okay
now he
has an important test or now
it's thanksgiving and like i don't you
know i just i'm like i don't know what
to do or when or how
yeah to bring it up
um
what is uh who what does thanksgiving
look like for you guys
um we would go to his family's house
just
with it's like his family reunion so we
would just go there for the day
yeah that would be
intense but um part of me
i don't think
the news will be so shocking i mean it
will be shocking but he won't be like
i never saw this coming because i when
you said that he probably kind of has an
idea already because of the distance or
you know i feel like he'll be like okay
not shocked like he was the first time
he even found any of this out um
he'll be shocked
yeah because you've probably done a
really damn good job of convincing him
that nothing else happened
yeah that's very true yeah so he's gonna
be shocked he's probably gonna be
shocked as much by your dishonesty as by
what happened
yeah definitely
i'm thinking in my head right now
whether you have this conversation
before or after
right um
part of me thinks the right thing to do
is to not
go pretend with all of his family
yeah
and
to
get a babysitter for the kids and
um
have a conversation with him over the
next couple of days now we're filming
this show the week of thanksgiving and
so it won't come out until december but
we're filming it now and so okay um
the other part of me says what's another
three days what do you think
um
i think i
i just am ready to
get it done yeah
um
because
i just the thought of even continuing on
is
really hard i don't want to move i don't
want to like ruin thanksgiving but also
or make that a bad memory
so what i'll tell you this is gonna i'm
gonna sound harsh okay but just know
what i'm saying you've already ruined
thanksgiving
okay
okay and so now it's a matter of
um
thanksgiving will be a hard season for
you y'all as a couple for the next
several years
okay and jim's will be a hard
conversation for y'all as a couple for
the next however long you know what i
mean that's that's that's in stone
that's there yeah yeah um
i'm glad to hear you say that my gut
tells me is you get a babysitter today
for the kids okay
and
i'm gonna tell you what i would do off
the top of my head okay
okay i would have a place to stay for me
okay and i would have this conversation
um in a private place if you think for a
second it's gonna go
i mean it sounds like he's a safe guy
he's not gonna he's definitely not okay
um these conversations are often great
with a counselor with somebody else
there okay um if you have a mentor
couple that knows you might want to let
them know that this is happening and
they can be there with you or if you
have full trust and
uh my wife would want me to have this
conversation with her in person
right because then she could kill me and
no one would ever ever find the body
right
right but
every couple's different
okay um but you need to get your kids
out of the home and then have a place to
go and you can offer it
i've got a hotel that i've put a deposit
on and i'm willing to go if you want me
to go spend the night somewhere else
right and he may say no i don't want
that whatever but i think that's a fair
statement just you may need a knight to
cool off
yeah okay and know that
he may say i don't want you coming
around my family during things our
family during thanksgiving um or maybe
we're going to do thanksgiving or none
of us are going you know everything gets
sideways and that's where you need to be
pretty loose hold everything pretty
loose and be accommodating um because
you're gonna blow his world up
yep for a second time right
yes
if you could go back and do this over
again would you do it different what
would you do different
i would have told him the first time he
found out that everything about
everything
for sure let's back up before that
oh
um
well i would not
be talking to somebody like i wasn't
married
or
not
how do i say it like i'm presenting
myself as single or maybe i just wasn't
fully committed to my marriage or
something
like
it it was out of control
yeah
so here we are right
yep so do me a favor natalie um i want
you to let me know how the conversation
goes okay
okay
and i'll also tell you one
piece of advice i learned from a crisis
responder that works here too
facts are your friends don't beat around
the bush be very direct and be very
short-winded
okay okay
got it i've been lying to you for the
last two months
i did sleep with this guy and i couldn't
lie to you anymore you're worth more
than that and i love you and i realized
i screwed up and i had to say it period
and that's where the conversation stops
okay okay
not a long drawn-out story of of of yeah
um but a
be direct and be incredibly honest
and um
and then go from there okay
okay i will
let me know how that goes
i don't know and um we'll be thinking
about you okay
okay thank you thank you so much all
right
whoo
man
whoa all right so we got a follow-up
here
um
seem to like do jumping jacks or
something for a second there's a couple
of heavy calls on the show
man
um here's a follow-up email from andrew
andrew uh the original call date uh
aired on august 18th 2021
and as episode 151
and here's what andrew writes he just
sent in an email he said hey i talked to
dr d a few months ago
i'm a recovering alcoholic and he
mentioned calling him back to see how
his advice worked regarding making
things right with my wife
included doing a gratitude list together
skin on skin contact prolonged eye
contact
without talking
it's been longer than the 30 days he
said but i'm still doing it and it's not
only brought me and my wife
closer but completely changed my life in
other areas as well thanks
thanks for that follow up andrew we
often over sensationalize or over
dramatize or over i need to get meds for
this i gotta do nine years of counseling
for this and sometimes it's as simple as
making a dedicated promise to your
partner
i'm gonna hold your hands
for 30 seconds in the morning i'm going
to hold your hands for 30 seconds in the
evening and i'm not going to say a word
i'm just going to look in your eyes
and i'm going to breathe i'm going to
drop my shoulders down
and we're going to do that every day for
30 days any and every married couple
dating couple i don't care who you are
dating talking i don't know do it with
your boss if it's not soup that'd be
super weird don't do it your boss
try
just try it
you wanna you wanna
go up a notch
have a gratitude journal of your own but
have one with your partner that stays on
your bed just have it there on the bed
and y'all do it at night time what's
five things you're grateful for
one of you write it down do that
together for 30 days you want to see
your marriage trans transform
it transforms and sometimes it
transforms because on day 7 or 8 you
have a real uncomfortable conversation
or one of you didn't want to do it the
other person says no we said we're going
to do it and it turns into a little spat
and then it turns into a honest
conversation about control and what are
we doing and why we didn't
do it for 30 days
thank you so much andrew
yeah
thank you so much andrew thank you so
much andrew thank you so much andrew i
needed that one at the end of the day
all right as we wrap up today's show
we do something a little bit different
for the song of the day
i asked james hey man um
i actually asked kyle one of the
engineers what's the song of the day
and james whispered to him you should
probably do this song so i'm gonna do a
little bit of a switcharoo
it's the worst song of all time ever
that was his idea not mine ever ever
ever
it's called today by smashing pumpkins
and it goes like this
just listen
today is the data's greatest day i've
ever known
can't live for tomorrow tomorrow's much
too long
i'll burn my eyes out before i get out
yolo
i wanted more than life could ever grant
me bored by the chore of saving face
today is the greatest day i've ever
known
i can't wait for tomorrow i might not
have that long
yolo i'll tear my heart out before i get
out pink ribbon scars that never forget
i tried so hard to cleanse these regrets
my angel wings were bruised and
restrained my belly stings
but today is the greatest day i've ever
known
it's the worst
it's the worst i was expecting the billy
corgan voice too
i don't even want to hate on that one i
can't do that to myself not after this
show see you soon on the dr john delaney
show